um hello everyone uh welcome to pi data
global 2021 uh i'm conrad one of the
co-chairs conference uh we're very happy
today to have uh vincente here with us
talking to us about uh introduction to
quantum computing with python and uh
qsf
thanks
thank you very much conrad and thank you
everybody for your time
and
i as kondra said like my name is vicente
and today i'm going to talk about
quantum computing python and how you can
connect both of them using kiskit
so within this talk i will be talking
and what is quantum computing what are
the difference with classical computing
and i will go through some real world
applications right now
then i will move to the ibm quantum
environment how to use it how to get
access and i will talk a little bit
about kiskit and then we will go
together through a notebook and seeing
how to
execute
one very simple experiment using quantum
computing
so first of all a little bit about me
and my name is vicente i've been 15
years working with data mainly with
anything that you can think of rational
databases no sequel big data on premises
on the cloud and in my free time i like
to to play with other different
technologies and areas main the main
ones genomic cyber security and this one
that is quantum computing so feel free
after this talk to connect with me in
linting or in any other platform if you
are interested in talking about data
quantum computing
so first of all let's go about what is
quantum computing
uh for those of you that have heard
about the term but are not that familiar
with it quantum computing is based on
quantum mechanics and quantum mechanics
is basically a theory in physics
that describes the physical properties
of subatomic particles so what that
means
that means that when you go into the
subatomic area
particles behave in a very interesting
way so basically you have particles that
when you are not observing them they
behave as waves when you are observing
them they behave as particles and they
will collapse to a specific value there
are two main
properties that we are interested on and
i will explain later one of them is the
entanglement and basically what happens
when you are entangling
two particles is that
the value that one of them collapse the
other one will collapse to exactly the
same value
so one example i have two particles and
one i have it on my own the other one is
in australia for example in the other
part of the world so when the particle
that i have collapsed to one specific
value the one that is in australia will
collapse to exactly the same value
another of the interested
properties of quantum computing is the
superposition superposition is basically
that
one particle is gonna have any value
between zero and one i will go deeper
about this
in other slides but basically
everybody knows the schrodinger cut
example and this is what is based the
superposition
so if we go to a very simple comparison
between quantum computing and classical
computing
classic computing
work with bits and as you know bits are
one or zero that's it
because we are using superposition in
quantum computing a cubit like what
could be a quantum bit
may have any value between zero and one
and this is very important because we
are going to use this later and this is
what gives its performance and its
benefits to quantum computing
it allows you to store much more
information using quantum computing
that's classical computing meanwhile
with one bit you can store only one
state zero or one with one qubit in
quantum computing you can store any
value between 0 and 1. what you will
have is a probability of that specific
qubit being 0 or being 1
and again i will go later deeper about
this there are other principles that we
are very interested in
in quantum computing and you have phase
you have entanglement as i said before
you have interference
but that is something that you must keep
in mind and here are the challenges that
we have right now in quantum computing
like all of this sounds awesome it's
more power more storage
but
there are some challenges one of them is
that quantum computing right now is in
its infants state what do i mean with
this right now if you want to code
in quantum computing you have to program
circuits so you will have to use gates
imagine classical computing having to
code circuits using add or xor gates in
quantum computing you will have to do
something like that
additionally uh
right now the computers don't have as
many qubits as we would want to if you
read the news and that is now like a new
company that is developing like personal
computers for quantum computing and i
think that they have five qubits so this
is the states in which we are now right
now there are only like five qubits
if you want to get a personal quantum
computer and finally that is the
probabilistic nature because when you
put your qubits in superposition any
value between zero and one and what you
have is a probability of that qubit
being zero or being one you can't run
only once your experiment you will need
to run it several times and get the most
common result
and again i will go deeper about this
later
so
one of the challenges as i was saying
before is that right now this is in its
infant's state it's not like i can buy a
quantum computer and i can get it into
my house what you have here on the left
is the famous google seeker more quantum
computer and you can see it's taking
like a huge room and on the right if we
want to compare with
the moment in which we had the classical
computing
uh at the same level uh what you see on
the right is the bomb and is the machine
that was used to decode the enigma
machine so this is where we are right
now with quantum computing
so okay
it's very powerful there are some
challenges but uh
said that there are a lot of companies
governments
and areas in the industry in which they
are pushing a lot of quantum computing
and this is because regardless of the
challenges that we have right now they
see a lot of benefits now and in the
short and long term so i will go through
some of the
real world applications that you could
use this
this is a very old
new from the newspaper i think that has
already like four or five years and this
is when china was testing quantum
entanglement for communications so think
on this when we were talking before
about entanglement when you have two
particles and you generate them together
and you put them in an entangled state
and you send one to one part of the
world and you send the other to the
other part of the world because you know
that when one of them is gonna
collapse
to one specific value the other one is
gonna do it as well
is something that you should be able to
use for communications imagine very fast
communications and communication that
nobody can interfere so as you can see
here is something that some governments
are already testing
additionally there is a lot of
performance with some specific
algorithms
what that means
ensure that you have read some of the
news like people are trying to scare
like oh quantum computing is going to
break our encryptions where right now we
don't have the power there are not
enough qubits for that to happen
but in the pace that we are progressing
there will be a moment in which quantum
computers will have enough qubits to be
able to break by brute force encryption
so as you can see it's an area in which
we want to keep our eyes on that we are
aware that there are some challenges but
there may be lots of benefits in
performance in the future
so now that you know a little bit more
about quantum computing
where is it right now what are the
challenges where is it going i can
imagine that you said like okay
i unsolved i want to play with this i
want to start working with this i want
to get involved so that is a very
easy way to do any and that is using ibm
quantum environment
so because it's not that easy to get a
quantum computer you will have to get
used to it through uh cloud providers
similar to what you do with aws with
azure with other cloud providers you
will need to uh use it through cloud
vendors so how do you do this um the
easiest from my point of view and
obviously this is my point of view is
the ibm
quantum environment is free
it's easy to use you just need to create
your ibm id and you can start using it
it's going to provide to you two
different ways of working with quantum
computing one of them is going to be
through a ui so you will be very visual
working with circuits and creating them
and executing and the other is using
python and keyskit with jupiter
notebooks
so this is how it would look the visual
circuit creation in ibm
as i said before it's very visual
something very interesting is that it
generates automatically code for you
based on the circuit
this code maybe open qsm or keyskit
the open qsm is basically assembly code
the kiskit is the one that we are
interested that is available with python
so let me try to share
my
web browser
and we
uh
yes let me see if it works
happy days and this is what you should
be able to see
when you log in in the ibm quantum
environment so basically you would have
the quantum composer that is the one
that i was talking for visually creating
your circuits so if i launch it
if you are a very visual person what you
see here is a circuit you should be able
to add gates taking them out remember
what they said before the way in which
this works for here is that
basically
you
need to work with circuits the way in
which we code is with circuits this is a
very visual way of doing it you can add
different gates and what you see here on
your right is this environment creating
the code for you you can create it in
assembly or you can create it in kiskit
so when you start working with this when
you start playing it's going to be very
interesting to play around create your
circuits then see the different results
that you would get from there
so this is the visual path but if you
are more of a coding person like me
let me come back to my presentation
what we are interested is basically in
working with kiskit
so
there is that option as well using the
ibm quantum environment you have what
they call the ibm quantum lab and that
is basically
that is basically jupiter notebooks
and that is something that i want all of
you to be aware and is that
you don't need to use the ibm quantum
environment i am doing this because it's
easy for a presentation and it's going
to make my life way easier everything is
going to work perfectly i'm not going to
have any problem but you should be able
to use this on your local just
installing kiskit you can install it
with pip easy pc you install it you can
use it with your notebooks
but for this presentation i will use the
the quantum lab so once that you have
started you will be able to use kiskit
what is kiski kiskit is a high level
code language created by ibm and the
idea is to be able to code quantum
experiments using python its open source
is created by ibm and is
the the standard in all the ibm
environments and is using even out of
the ibm environments
so if you log in there you should be
able to use it as any jupiter notebook
there are different notebooks that are
available for you the one that is the
more interesting is the getting started
is the one that they have been tuning a
little bit and is the one that we are
going to go through together later but
before we go together through the
notebook there are some basics that i
want you to be aware of
so
the first of all i will go through the
different back-ends options that you
have
then i will go through how to create a
basic circuit how to execute it and how
to check the results
so first of all
there are different ways in which you
can execute your quantum environments
you can execute it on the cloud using
for example ibm quantum environment and
what you will do is execute it in the
quantum machines that will be parts
packed they will be sent to a queue and
eventually it will be run in one of the
quantum computers that ibm has but the
easy part is that you should be able to
simulate it locally or in the ibm
quantum environment and in order to do
that what we use is kiskit ir that is
included in the kiskit libraries so one
that you install kiskit is available for
you and there are different
simulators see different backends the
most common is the state vector the
state vector basically what is going to
do when you execute your quantum
experiment is return to you a vector
with a states for your quantum
experiment you can use as well unitary
simulator basically what is going to
return for you is a matrix that is going
to represent your experiment and finally
you can use the assembly simulator so
there are different backends i we will
execute an experiment through all of
them and it will show you the
differences but you need to be aware
that there are these options for you the
one that is the most common is the state
vector is the one that i usually use
when i do my experiment as well you can
run it in any quantum computer
so let's say that we start creating our
base circuit well i what i have here in
these
snapshots is basically the same circuit
that i was showing to you in the visual
composer so what we are going to do is
recreate that circuit using code using
python and using key skill key for you
import quiz kit this is the library that
you are going to use as you can see is
very easy to create a quantum circuit
with just three qubits you just need to
call quantum circuit the parameter is
three boom you have your circuit with
three qubits and then when you start
doing is because remember that we are
programming circuits what you will do is
start adding gates to different queue
bits
of your circuit here what we do is
adding a hadamard gate to the qubit zero
and then adding a couple of c not gates
so
easy to visualize your circuit uh
keyskit works very well with maclaurin
lead so you you should be able to
basically using the draw function to
show how it's going to look your circuit
and now this is interesting part you
have different back-ends and depending
on the back-end that you execute
your circuit you're gonna have different
results what i am showing here to you is
how to simulate
in both back ends state vector and qsm
on the left what you see is how you
should execute this circuit in the state
vector on the right is what you see how
you would execute it in qsm it's very
similar at the end of the day basically
you are explaining to the code okay this
is the backend that i want to use on the
left we are using the state vector
simulator on the right we are using the
qsn simulator you execute it and you get
the results and then depending on the
way in which you want to see the results
there are different ways so
on the left if we have been using a
state vector and you want to check the
results what you're going to get as i
said before is a vector with the
different probabilities for each one of
the states so as you can see here we
were putting it in superposition in
entanglement sorry so you will have half
of the probability for zero zero
half of the probability for one one if
you want to visualize this this is how
you can do it again using math plot leaf
on the right is even easier
you don't want to get any visualization
about the states you just want to see
the results so what you do is execute
the experiment
1000 times and then you get the counts
for the different results
remember because what i said before
about being a probabilistic nature
because once that you put your qubits
between zero and one in that state
what you're gonna get is a probability
this qubit can collapse to zero with a
probability of fifty percent can
collapse to one with a probability of 50
percent so when you execute this
experiment
a number of times you will have what you
see on your right 50 percent of the
times more or less
zero zero fifty percent of the time more
or less one one again this is because
the probabilistic nature
of the
of the quantum computing
and now before going to the next steps i
have time so what we are gonna do is we
are gonna run it on our own
so if we go again here we go to the lab
as i was explaining before let me launch
my server
it time it out
it's going to make me look bad
this is what happened with
the typical
demos
okay let me launch my lap
and basically what i am launching here
is jupiter notebooks so you will you are
going to have different options in the
ibm
q experience basically you are going to
have the option of running jupiter
notebooks different and different
versions but the one that we are
interested in getting started with kisky
this is the one that i have been
showcasing with the snapshot but we are
going to run on our own so once you open
this and this is available for all of
you
the easy part is basically to import
kiskit we do it no problem at all this
is how you create your circuit with
three qubits it's basically creating
your circuit
and this is where we are going to
recreate
the visual circuit that i was showing
you before we are adding a hadamard gate
we are adding different synod gates and
we want to visualize it so if we go to
visualize it
again this is how my circuit is going to
look now this is the interesting part
let's see how we execute it with
different backends that they have been
showing before and let's see what are
the results for each one
so first of them we can use the state
vector simulator this one remember what
i said before it's going to return to
you a vector with the probabilities for
each different state of your circuit so
we decide we request this back-end
we run our circuit
we get the
result and then we want to see how it
looks
because we have our circuit in an
entangled position both qubits are going
to collapse always to the same value
so what this means is that our result is
going to be always zero zero zero
or one one one and this is because our
qubits are collapsing always to all
zeros or always to all ones because the
probabilistic nature what you have is a
state in which fifty percent could
collapse to zero zero zero fifty percent
could collapse to one one one so this is
what you can see in this visual
representation here
if you execute it in the unitary backend
what you will have is a matrix
representing the state of your circuit
but the most easy to follow the results
is the open qsm and i am going to show
you why
we execute it in our open qsm backend
we execute it 1000 times because we are
interested in see the distribution of
our results and we get the counts what
you get with accounts is the number of
times that the results happened and the
number of times that there should happen
because we know that we are in an
entangled position
when we execute this and we get the
results we are going to get roughly 50
of the times zero zero zero fifty
percent of the times one one one
again because the probabilistic nature
if i execute this again the numbers are
gonna change slightly
and this is because you're not gonna get
always exactly the same results as you
can see they change it a little bit if i
execute it again
let me go with it the counts will change
again
but
always they are gonna be roughly 50 and
50
and this is because me personally
encoded in this circuit
an entanglement in which i know that all
the qubits in that circuit are gonna
collapse always to zero zero zero or to
one one one
so okay let me come back to
the slides
and now that
you know what is quantum computing why
it's so interesting you are a little bit
more familiar with kiss kit you you
should be able to install it locally or
to use the ibm q experience
and you are able to go there and check
different notebooks that they have for
starters or you can even work with that
with your own ideas so what would be the
next steps let's say that you love this
and you say vicente i am only i love it
i want to play with this so my
recommendation for next steps is set up
your environment you don't really need
to use the ibmq experience environment
you should be able to install kiskit on
your local machine and be able to
execute it
and read some material i really really
really recommend this book i'm not
getting any fee for that but i do really
recommend it it's really good
programming quantum computer brings a
lot of examples a lot of different
algorithms that you can play with and i
do recommend it take a look and play
with channel algorithms and some of the
code samples that they provide
and yes my final advice is to experiment
experiment experiment play around with
it right now i am a data person so i am
playing with different data processing
experiments they are a little bit
complex this is why i not show it here
it would take like a little bit of time
to explain the different algorithms and
the different things that i am trying
but you can do the same you can go in
your own laptop you can play around you
can install it and check it out this
book get inspired by feed by some of the
tutorials that you have in the ibm q
experience uh
best of all if you have any doubt you
have any
problem any doubt about data about
quantum computing feel free to connect
with me in linting and i am happy to
talk about this this is one of my
passions
and i am happy to to answer any question
in the slack channel or connect with me
offline through linting uh yeah come
back to me with any question any doubt
you may have
uh i want to thank you for all your time
and this is the end of my presentation
within tying i let five minutes so thank
you very much everybody for your time
thank you vincente now stop the
recording now
okay